we're live in five four three
let's begin shall we
[Music]
in life
discoveries usually lead to four
questions
the only constant variable is the
unexpected
we can't control it
it's only when you look backwards that
you see how it was all connected
let's begin shall we
that's perfect I'd like to cook
mystery
you're on the verge of a major
scientific breakthrough this institution
has a reputation based on the
world-class scientists not the series of
a pretty lab tech we have rules you're
firing me
just stop you crying it's a sign of the
times
I would like to offer you a job as the
host of our cooking show are you
concussed no you are poised to become a
TV star welcome to the final show we're
live in
[Music]
supper at 6
do I need a catchphrase don't overthink
it never understood what that meant I
stand proudly with the overlooked
Workhorse of the kitchen women and baked
potatoes
[Music]
you've got something almost no one has
a platform what you say matters politics
don't belong in the kitchen a man wants
his wife to make him a drink after a
long day at work why do you assume that
his day was longer than hers why don't
you make the drink
[Music]
most in this world not because you are
pretty not because you are smart but
because you love me and I love you
do it anyway
your ability to change everything starts
here
children's at the table your mother
needs a moment to herself